من رام الله ينضم الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ليس من المستغرب ان
ينتهي الاجتماع الوزاري المصغر دون الوصول
الى اتفاق حول المرحله التاليه من الحرب
نتيجه كل الخلافات التي ظهرت على السطح
الايام
الماضيه لا بل نتنياهو من بدايه الاجتماع
الذي استمر حتى الثانيه بعد منتصف الليله
الماضيه وهو اجتماع الكابينت وهو الطاقم
الوزاري الامني المصغر قال لهم انه يتم
بحث امور او قضايا دراميه في هذا الاجتماع
وسيتم بحث القضايا المعتاده لذلك فسر
الوزراء كما نقلت عنهم اذاعه الجيش وغيرهم
ان نتنياهو تهرب وللمره الثالثه من اجراء
اي بحث في هذه القضيه الخلافيه بين اقطاب
حكومته فهناك في حكومته من هم على شاكله
سموتريتش وبن كفير الذان يدعوان الى
احتلال كامل لقطاع غزه والبقاء فيه واقامه
مستوطنات وتهجير سكانه وهناك من يدعو الى
ضروره ان تكون هناك رؤيه اسرائيليه لليوم
التالي ول الجهه التي او الاليه التي
ستقوم باداره شان القطاع بعد ان تنسحب منه
اسرائيل نتنياهو ذهب ومنذ بدايه الجلسه
وهي المره الثالثه التي يفعلها مؤخرا في
هذا الخصوص للتنصل والتهرب من الموضوع
للبحث علما ان هناك قيادات امنيه وعسكريه
اسرائيليه كبيره تطالبه وايضا الولايات
المتحده تطالبه بان يكون هناك قرار
واستراتيجيه اسرائيليه واضحه بهذا الشان
لكن نتنياهو يدرك جيدا بان الموضوع قد
يكون عامل تفجير داخل حكومته بين قطبيها
قطبها اليمين العنصر المتطرف ممثلا بموتش
وبن كفير وقطبها الاخر ممثلا ب وزراء حزب
المعسكر معسكر الدوله وايضا القياده
العسكريه التي يمثلها تحديدا جالانت وزير
الدفاع هنا كان التهرب واقتصرت البحث في
الاجتماع وان كان طويلا على قضايا تتعلق
باحط امنيه مطوله حول الوضع الامني
والعسكري في قطاع غزه وعلى الحدود مع
لبنان وتقديم ايضا سرد حول توجهات هذا
عفوا
هذا الامر الامر الثاني كان قد طرح اجتماع
الكابينيت جاء بعد اجتماع مجلس الحرب هذه
الليله وكان قد طرح فيها ايضا منحى جديد
مقترح من اطراف الوساطه القطريه والمصريه
بخصوص الدخول في عمليه مفاوضات جديده
لابرام صفقات تبادل جديده للاسرى لكن
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقول بان اي مقترح
يتم تقديمه ويدعو لوقف فوري اطلاق النار
وانسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه هو مرفوض من قبلها في هذه
المرحله وحاولت الترويج وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ومصادرها ايضا الى ان هناك
مقترح يدعو الى ان يكون هناك افراج كامل
عن جميع الاسرائيليين المحتجزين والاسرى
في قطاع غزه في مقابل السماح او كما
اسمتها ابعاد قاده حماس الى الخارج
وانسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي بالكامل من قطاع
غزه هذا المنح هو قالوا بانه مرفوض حتى من
قبل اسرائيل لانها لا تريد ان يكون هناك
وقف فوري لعمليات عملياتها الحربيه في
داخل القطاع ومصادرها العسكريه تتحدث عن
انه على الرغم من ان الوضع معقد ومركب جدا
تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس والمناطق الوسطى
من قطاع غزه والقتال ضار لكن قواتهم تسجل
تقدما وذهب جانس الوزير في مجلس الحرب الى
القول امس بان هناك انجازات تتراكم وستتضح
لاحقا وان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيحقق اهدافه
على حد تعبيره شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري